hello everyone how are you guys doing
hope you guys are having a wonderful day
and today we are here with worthless to
Wall Street episode 12 so basically
we're going to get into this right away
but first I have some things to say so
as you can see I'm here this is serious
stuff so I've changed the game volume on
my mic and I haven't really had set
times when I change it so right now my
voice is going to be a little lower I do
believe then the rest of the video so
you've been warned that if those clips
scare you because they're louder I told
you so
anyways other than that I would like to
advertise my clan chat to you guys
small exp lab this is where we're gonna
try to just have some of you guys who
ever enjoy my video just come and hang
out man just talk to me it's a good old
time but nonetheless I think we'll get
right into the video but yeah remember
to join that claim chat all right let's
go with the merchants we're starting
this episode with milk let's go and here
we go boys 500 of the crystal keys made
didn't take too long at all we're gonna
see what they buy for and they bought
for 41 $4.99
so gonna sell them onto the fat and once
those all sell as you can see we'll get
pretty much 21 mil from that and with
all that combined we are up to 81 mils
so sick there we go
so all of the crystal keys have sold
didn't take too long at all I'll
actually know it did I [__] lied it
took like two and a half hours and
nothing else is bought and I hate my
life
I wanna drown my soul so here we are two
stopped on in the morning and we had one
merch the entire night really and here
it is so as you can see you can't see
actually I'm lying bought ad full-time
for twenty nine point three mil and was
able to sell it on for thirty point
three other than that I have no clue
what the prices for anything is and I
think a lot of the margins are gone so
I'm gonna have to just go and refine
some items I think all right let me
preface this clip by saying someone
decided to go to the dentist earlier
that day so yeah it's kind of hear me
yeah just blame it on that all right
here we got a moment of truth
so tell me breakfast is my saying I put
in these offers about a day ago I ended
up not coming home later that night and
is the morning the next day so I was
able to sell off these Furi ornament
kits which is good and the eternal
glorious did not buy which is depressing
because that means their price went up
and I wasn't able to snipe a few however
I'm not too down about it because I
probably I was really close to actually
getting some I could have made a little
bit of money I think this one should
have bought but this one obviously was a
lot lower so that was more like a backup
if they dropped a little bit well once
you a gez concert it was [__] amazing
but nonetheless left these offers in to
try and be able to get a snipe on some
of these things really this is not even
a crazy snake this would have been nice
but the price could have dropped and the
occult ornament kid I actually thought I
could have got so as you can see we
still have all of our money we haven't
done much at all I think still eighty
1.20 was not able to sell this light
ballista back however I just had three
insta buys so I'm going to put these
down to probably 30 30 K
and probably put in a pretty low offer
for some light ballistas right now
because because that dude just got done
someone just sold a ton of them pretty
much is what I'm trying to say so the
five price could be a bit low and I may
be able to make some money off of that
effect hey there we go so torch ornament
kit has sold on which means I'm probably
just gonna end up buying these I saw
earlier that I couldn't buy torch your
ornament kits for 11350 okay so I'm just
gonna put some in for that because that
would still be a 400k profit so by 3 for
that and then saradomin got sword as you
can see 16 mil is what I bought it for
16 points debris however I think I can
sell it on for around 18 ish so I'm
gonna try to do that and we'll see what
we can do and another God Wars warming
kit has bought I'm gonna try to sell
this one on however for 9275 so I won't
be making that much off of this one go
back from the dentist so if I sound a
little weird that is why but moment of
truth let's see what we got here and
well it's not bad I guess our armadale
kit has sold for a 275k profit another
light bullet says sold
nope tour tournament gets us bought half
bought and yeah the saradomin sword
Charlie gonna be in there for a little
while I would imagine one little merch
I'm gonna try to do so I think I bought
my limit of you seeds however as you can
see the you saplings sell on 491 K and
you seeds I just bought a ton of them
for around pretty much eighty six case
so I should be making 5k per you see
which would mean this would be a about a
mill margin I guess that I could be
making hopefully the you saplings don't
drop on me now actually got a armored
dog dad sword canoe and
was that up for a little bit of profit I
don't know 200k is not too bad I guess
for first leash it as a lot happened
since I last looked at this account god
damn all right we're gonna sell this on
for 945 K my there we go
9:45 okay I'm gonna sell that on as you
can see our our middle God's work it did
sell however two more BOTS I'm gonna
list both of those up for two point or
nine to three nine K and then we will go
from there nine to three nine okay list
those up and as you can see our
saradomin godsword kit which we bought I
think for round you cannot see here but
I think is around sixteen point four
mill ended up buying so that is insane
we made a mill profit off of this
ornament kit which means I'm definitely
doing that [__] again because I'd be
crazy not to right alright so something
pretty strange I just took in nab from 6
p.m. until 10 so I don't I can't explain
it but uh here we go
so stuff is definitely buying and
selling in here so all of these Elder
chaos tops are sold going to five one to
see what I need to sell them on for
surrender put in like 950 K something
like that as you can see selling it
actually exactly for 950 J between
dreaming a ton of money off of these
alone probably around the mill if I tend
to check it out so yeah to 20k off of
each one so we're missing one point one
bill on those all of our armadyl
godsword ornament kits have sold and I
definitely should have potted these you
seeds before I took that nap but it is
what it is so we're going to go and
probably do those right now I think
here we go trading over all of the you
saplings that I have made so we're gonna
sell these on I got to see what price I
can sell them for however I do believe I
bought all of the you see it's are about
85 K or 86 K so as you can see that
actively traded price is terrifying 89k
you saplings and you
see they're still going down and I
regret not doing this earlier hey that's
what I like to see it's been a while
I've had this off friend since probably
like 6 o'clock or somewhere around there
and it finally finally is bought so
we're gonna see what we can sell this
thing on for I think I could sell it for
about seventeen point four maybe there
hasn't been one bought in a while though
so that's it's the one problem with this
but I think I should be able to sell it
on 417 400 try that out make a mil on
this again hopefully now all of the
light boluses have sold and you saplings
have as well so we got a lot of cash
right now probably just gonna keep these
offers and these hopefully will sell and
yeah we'll see what we can do with 34
mil well here we are about to go to bed
and gonna throw in and offer for some
torture ornament kits real quick alright
so this is what my offers are gonna look
like before I go to bed and now I'm
gonna hard cut to the morning where all
the stuff is bought and sold I'm gonna
be really excited cuz I'm about to make
a ton of money right oh okay way to go
see all my items that have bought
surprise [__] another instance
of being able to buy up here on margin
so basically I went 2-0 page 3 bought
one for 6 under K then I put in an offer
for for for 695 was only able to buy two
at 646 and then I sold off the 600 K one
for 545 which means that I initially had
a 55 K margin and I bought it all the
way up into a hundred and fifty K margin
so yeah that's exactly what I'm talking
about and if you can spread this across
a few accounts it's an insane money
making method but it is risky because if
they if people have enough page threes
they can sell it on to you and you've
gotta be fun it's been a while since
I've had my last clip but here we go so
saradomin godsword
ornament kit has sold um we made
probably about 600 K off of that I do
believe so I'm gonna obviously buy
another one since this thing's been
working pretty well for us so far
hey and then literally not even
ten minutes later I made a little
another saradomin godsword kit for 15.3
if I can sell this one for 16.9 again
I'm gonna go 1680 10k or 12 K something
like that I'm definitely willing to buy
another one of these so I'll put another
offer I'm gonna lower it just a little
bit to like fifteen point one ish but
this is still a huge merch if I'm able
to do this one alone that's like one
point seven mil all right the Sun oh
this could be a [__] up merch I really
don't know the price of Third Age
helmets just jumped a ton today and I
figured I'd get in on the high margin
that OS buddy said it had and yeah we're
gonna go from there
not really sure at all about this but
we'll figure this out well moment of
truth ladies and gentlemen so coming
back from work and we finished selling
the Third Age full home which is
actually insane to be totally honest
because looking at 34.6 and I sold it
for 35.9 which means I made 1.3 mil on
that none of the saradomin got sword
stuff sold little depressing I could be
able to well I will be able to change a
price at least to that fourteen point to
one didn't buy because then I would have
known I [__] up a while I am going to
bed this should be about where we end
off for the night so as you can see I'm
going to up this Sara DOMA godsword
ornament kit offer I'm probably gonna
buy two overnight or at least try to for
about fourteen point four mil 2014 400
okay because apparently I just can no I
have to explain it to you again I guess
alright so here we are with the clip I
just bought a Bandos got sword ornament
kit I'm rear according over this later
because my mom was working out
downstairs so I could not record at the
time because all you would have heard
was the [__] Christ dog in the
background that the treadmill that's but
that's what I was looking for anyways we
bought the band those two gods were torn
make it for Fiverr and sell it on for
six and as you can see we sold off all
of our saradomin God wars ordinary God's
or dormant kits some of them being said
I start taking out some offers here so
we're gonna switch on over to my
characters you guys actually have
something pretty
to look at I guess all right nonetheless
that'll do it for the video so I added
up what we were at at the time and I
believe we are ending off this video at
89.5 mill I have a lot of leftover clips
so I kinda have to do that in the fly
pretty sure I did that well nonetheless
hope you guys enjoyed the video if you
guys did feel free to leave a like you
guys have anything you want to prove me
on and prove me because of anything you
want me to approve spawn feel free to
drop that in the comments down below or
you want to show a little bit of love
you comment something cool or subscribe
nonetheless that'll be it for me today
hope you guys have a wonderful day and
peace hit it with the outro